hola qué tal yo soy fernanda rocha y me
da muchísimo gusto estar aquí con
ustedes y básicamente lo que voy a hacer
el día de hoy es contarte una historia
esta historia comienza exactamente hace
11 años bueno a decir verdad puede que
date de más tiempo porque desde muy niña
me comencé a preocupar por el tiempo me
daba mucha angustia que los días se
acabaran que mis momentos favoritos
terminarán por acabarse
pero este evento que te voy a platicar
puede que sea el punto de inflexión
en el que realmente me di cuenta del
tema del tiempo resulta que el 5 de
agosto del 2010 google publicó un
artículo en el que decía que según sus
registros y hasta ese momento existían
129 millones
864 mil ochocientos ochenta libros
y ahí fue cuando caí en la cuenta que
definitivamente
nunca me iba a dar tiempo de leer todos
los libros que quería leer y eso me
abrumó me hizo sentir triste porque fue
una realidad que me cayó como una roca
encima y dije no voy a poder leer los
libros que quiero leer no voy a poder
ver las películas que quiero ver no voy
a poder ver las series que quiero ver
entonces qué estoy haciendo para que
existe en este planeta pero la verdad no
todo estaba perdido porque hice cálculos
y dije ok bueno el promedio de vida
puede que llegue a ser de 90 años
entonces voy a leer tantos libros al día
pero ni aún con eso me iba a dar ni de
chiste ni de cerca tiempo de leer tantos
libros sin embargo en ese mismo año
meses antes en junio para ser exactos se
publicó otro artículo un artículo en el
que ibm presentaba a watson un sistema
basado en inteligencia artificial capaz
de responder a preguntas bien formuladas
en un lenguaje natural desarrollado por
la empresa que ya mencioné la empresa
estadounidense ibm
si es más adelante en enero del 2011
watson esta inteligencia artificial
derrotó a los mejores jugadores de yo
perdí en ese juego y ahí fue cuando
eligen si por fin entonces eso significa
que si juntamos esta idea catastrófica
que yo tenía de no me va a dar tiempo
pero al mismo tiempo estaba ocurriendo
la inteligencia artificial jugando y
derrotando a los seres humanos
dirigentes eso es el punto eso es lo que
verdaderamente nos va a dar la
inteligencia artificial no nos va a dar
más inteligencia bueno si por un lado
pero lo más importante es que va a traer
consigo tiempo artificial ya se te lo
voy a explicar está claro que los seres
humanos no somos software
y bueno eso lo entendemos pero en una
analogía lo somos sin embargo no
aprendemos ni podemos ser programados
como el software úno porque todavía no
encontramos cuál es exactamente el
código del lenguaje de nuestro cerebro
pero en segundo lugar porque nuestro
cerebro además de esas conexiones
involucra variables como la cultura la
transmisión cultural los sesgos mira por
ejemplo tú estás aprendiendo algo de
esto espero que si de esto que estoy
diciendo sin embargo no lo estás
haciendo a través de mis datos de
entrada lo estás haciendo a través de
los propios estás aprendiendo de mi
comprensión y de mi capacidad de
transmisión digerida a escala humana con
todos mis límites mis carencias y todos
mis sesgos personales pero no tengo una
manera de permitirte a ti que así como
yo lo digerí con las conexiones que mis
neuronas hicieron tú lo puedes replicar
tú lo haces a tu manera y a eso me
refiero cuando no podemos ser
programados como
no hay una forma todavía de conectarnos
y que yo te pase exactamente las cosas
que pensé y como lo conecté tú vas a
sacar tus propias conclusiones y de
hecho lo haces con cada una de las cosas
que aprendes sin embargo esa es una de
las principales diferencias entre
nosotros y la inteligencia artificial la
inteligencia artificial si puede
aprender de la misma manera te lo voy a
mostrar con un juego que se puso mucho
de moda gracias a una serie de netflix
que es el ajedrez
en algún momento se creía que los
ajedrecistas mayores en edad le ganaban
a los ajedrecistas jóvenes pues por
cosas como la experiencia la misma edad
del aprendizaje eso fue muy válido en
mucho tiempo hasta que un día dejó de
serlo soy bien decir por ejemplo este
tipo de cosas de karpov en los años 80
cuando se enfrentó a kasparov por
ejemplo donde ahí se confirmaba que los
ajedrecistas más experimentados le
ganaban a los menos experimentados pero
hubo un momento cuando magnus carlsen
derrotó a vis na matan a un amante en
2013 y ahí se reveló algo extraño decía
que cárcel era 21 años más joven su
forma de juego parecía el de alguien
mayor y la gente empezó a decir hoy esta
teoría que teníamos sobre que los más
adultos le ganan a los más jóvenes era
errónea lo que diferenciaba el juego de
cárcel no era un tema de inteligencia ni
de coeficiente intelectual sino que él
había sido efectivamente entrenado por
inteligencias artificiales sí desde muy
niño él comenzó a competir con estas
inteligencias que estaban ya disponibles
en las computadoras y eso fue su
entrenamiento diario no aprendió cómo
los demás jugando con otros seres
humanos si no significa que no jugaba
con ellos pero la mayor parte del tiempo
jugaba contra estas inteligencias
artificiales
por lo tanto desarrolló un estilo de
juego mucho más matinal algo que
presionaba con fuerzas al final
explorando líneas de juego que parecían
inverosímiles para esa época poco
convencionales jugadas extraordinarias
que la gente no sabía realmente de donde
las había sacado y bueno resultó que
para beneficio de cárcer eso le dio una
ventaja y por fin logró derrotar a uno
de los ajedrecistas más importantes de
su era
en síntesis y regresando a la idea sobre
que yo no te puedo decir a ti mírate en
mi cerebro y aprende como yo aprendo
pues las inteligencias artificiales si
pueden hacerlo y la ventaja es que una
mente que es entrenada por inteligencia
artificial si puede aprender de la
inteligencia artificial y puedo aprender
estilos de juego en este caso del
ajedrez totalmente diferentes y eso es
porque la inteligencia artificial no
utilizas goss culturales que nosotros si
tenemos a la hora de transmitir
conocimiento cuando aprendemos de seres
humanos entre seres humanos para seres
humanos y eso es muy interesante no
significa que sea malo significa que
aprendemos de maneras distintas y que
cuando nos entren a una inteligencia
artificial en cualquiera vivida
habilidad nos elimina de alguna forma
estos sesgos de transmisión cultural
humana por lo tanto un jugador que es
entrenado en un circuito de aprendizaje
muy bien diseñado contra las
inteligencias artificiales
tú tiene una verdadera ventaja sobre
cómo juega un ser humano promedio y eso
es lo que yo he llamado años datos ya se
pasó ido hablar sobre esta idea de que
los años pero bueno hace cuenta es algo
más o menos así pero en lugar de
compararnos con otra especie es comparar
nos cuantos años en datos tenemos mira
piensa esto si yo ahorita te digo busca
algo en google vas a encontrar un montón
información esa información no estaba
disponible hace años por lo tanto tu
edad en datos significa que es mucho más
alta o más longeva que las personas que
vivieron cuando no existía google y eso
es lo que pasó contarse él realmente
aunque era joven pues podríamos decir
que tenía 200 años más de datos entonces
tenía 200 años en datos aunque su edad
fuera otra auto edad biológica
es aquí donde para mí viene la mayor
realización y esperanza sobre todo eso
la esperanza porque si yo estaba
preocupada y abrumada porque no me iba a
dar tiempo de leer todos los libros hoy
me doy cuenta que gracias a las
inteligencias artificiales pues ellas
pueden leer por mí toda esa data todos
esos libros y traerme lo mejor de cada
una de ellas es más también podrían
hacer un resumen una síntesis incluso si
avanza más como lo está haciendo ahora
podrían ellas tener una interpretación
como si yo estuviera interpretando
porque yo les podría transmitir esa
parte de mí es ese si esa forma de
interconectar y de replantear mis ideas
por lo tanto eso significa que por fin
esta preocupación que he tenido durante
muchos años puede que llegue a su fin
porque entonces estas inteligencias
artificiales podrían leer todos esos
libros y traerme esa información y
aumentar mi en datos mis años
datos en dos tres cuatro diez veces más
y eso para mí me da mucha esperanza
porque significa lo que verdaderamente
como lo dije al inicio trae la
inteligencia artificial consigo no es
solo inteligencia sino tiempo mira si me
conecto por ejemplo ahora mismo y
lograra encontrar la forma de enchufar
me una inteligencia artificial de una
manera correcta es más incluso de una
manera que no fuera totalmente
satisfactoria o eficiente yo podría o
estaría leyendo efectivamente lo que una
persona de mil años logró leer ya sé no
han existido personas de ser de esa edad
pero la inteligencia artificial tiene
acumulado esa cantidad de conocimiento
por lo tanto hoy mismo si yo lograra
conectarme en lugar de tener sólo 33
años tendría mil 33 años esos mil años
en datos más 33 de años biológicos y eso
lo puedes hacer tú tú has vivido muchos
años en datos porque me asiste
seguramente en una era de internet por
lo tanto tienes más edad en datos que
tus propios abuelos y es que todavía
están contigo
es sorprendente porque es una de las
cosas más ricas que hay y sobre todo de
las más invaluables
incluso ahora que no existen
dispositivos protésicos es decir no
tengo una prótesis un casco un chip como
el que quiere hacer el olmo dos cosas
todas estas tecnologías que pareciera de
ciencia ficción pero que son reales
aunque no tengamos todavía eso ya
tenemos más años datos que lo que
tuvieron nuestros abuelos o incluso
nuestros padres porque hemos tenido cada
vez más acceso a esa información
esa es la clave para comprender el
verdadero beneficio de la inteligencia
artificial
entender que es un tema más allá de la
inteligencia y que si la usamos a
nuestro favor podemos ganar uno de los
recursos más valiosos que tenemos como
seres humanos
tiempo así que está bien si pones a
sirio alexa o cualquier cosa al leer un
libro o si usas apps que te entregan
resúmenes está bien segura que te va a
decir no a eso es para la gente floja o
para la gente que no quiere involucrarse
en el conocimiento pero no es no tenemos
que verlo así lo tenemos que ver como
aliados porque imagínate si tú quieres
leer 100 libros pero solo tienes tiempo
para leer 2 la inteligencia artificial
podría leer los otros 98 por ti y eso
significa que habrá más oportunidades
para saber de todo y para saber de
muchas cosas y si a ti te abruma va la
idea de salir de la escuela o cambiar de
profesión porque decías no me va a dar
tiempo ya que ahora lo voy a hacer o
aquí ahora lo va a aprender esta podría
ser la oportunidad para lograrlo y lo
que tú te dedicas a aprender fotografía
la inteligencia artificial que podría
estar ayudando a aprender otras cosas
idiomas u otras cosas que te interesen y
eso significa que podríamos llegar un
momento de nuestras vidas de nuestra era
como como humanidad en la que ya no sólo
importará tu edad biológica esta idea de
que alguien es en 15 años no tienes
experiencia se eliminaría con esta idea
de los años o el tiempo artificial en
los años datos como ya lo nombre la
pregunta final para ti entonces sería
cuántos años datos crees que tienes hoy
ahora no quiero romantizar lo ya te
conté la parte que me entusiasma pero
también te voy a compartir la parte que
me preocupa hoy hay unos datos y bueno
hay muchos datos que dicen que pasamos
más o menos entre 8 10 15 horas vamos a
hacer un promedio pasamos 10 horas
frente a nuestras pantallas ya sea
estando en internet en redes sociales el
tema es que hacemos en ese tiempo
realmente le estamos sacando provecho
realmente estamos utilizando este tiempo
artificial a nuestro favor o por el
contrario nos estamos volviendo esclavos
de una pantalla en la que solo la usamos
para entretenernos para dormirnos para
quedarnos y en lugar de estar ganando
tiempo lo estamos perdiendo pues te
tengo una noticia sin solo lo estás
perdiendo debes saber y estar consciente
que ese tiempo no va a volver y eso es
muy importante ya sé es una como muy
lógico pero a veces se nos olvida se nos
olvida que ese tiempo no vuelve por lo
tanto si realmente queremos tener años
datos y extraer ese tiempo artificial de
las inteligencias artificiales
necesitamos es usar estas herramientas
esas pantallas esas tecnologías a
nuestro favor pedirles que hagan cosas
por nosotros que lean cosas por nosotros
que nos den resúmenes hoy en día ya hay
mucha tecnología democratizada puedes
google
inteligencias artificiales que hacen
resúmenes que escriben cosas que
comparten cosas y aprender de ellas
usarlas como esta herramienta para
extender tu tiempo no te encantaría
tener mil años en años datos así que
piensa bien en que usas tu tiempo y cómo
podrías ganar gracias a las
inteligencias artificiales más tiempo
artificial esto que yo me dio mucho
gusto de estar contigo soy fernanda
rocha y nos vemos en el futuro